We finished off the last
video in the Hadean Eon.
It was named for Hades or
the ancient Greek underworld.
Hades is also the
name of the god that
ran the Greek underworld,
Zeus's oldest brother.
And it was an appropriate
name, although the idea of,
the ancient Greek
notion of the underworld
isn't exactly the more
modern notion of Hell.
But it was a
hellish environment.
You had all this
lava flowing around.
You had things impacting
the Earth from space.
And as far as we
can tell right now,
it was completely
inhospitable to life.
And to make matters worse,
even though the Earth started
to cool down a little
bit, maybe the crust
became a little bit more solid.
Maybe the collisions started
to happen less and less,
as we started to go a few
hundred million years fast
forward.
After the Theia rammed
into the early earth
and formed the moon, there was
something called the Late Heavy
Bombardment.
And right now, the consensus
is that life, whatever
we are descended
from, would have
had to come about after
the Late Heavy Bombardment.
Because this was a time where
so many things from outer space
were hitting Earth, that it was
so violent, that it might have
killed off any kind of
primitive, self-replicating
organisms or molecules that
might have existed before it.
And I won't go into the physics
of the Late Heavy Bombardment.
But we believe that it happened,
because Uranus and Neptune--
so if this is the sun right
here-- that is the sun.
This is the asteroid belt.
That's outside the orbits
of the inner, rocky planets.
That Uranus and Neptune,
their orbits moved outward.
And I'm not going to
go into the physics.
But what that caused
is, gravitationally, it
caused a lot of the asteroids
in the asteroid belt
to move inward and start
impacting the inner planets.
And of course, Earth was
one of the inner planets.
And I should make the sun like
orange or something, not blue.
I don't want you to
think that's Earth.
And it also impacted the moon.
And it's more
obvious on the moon,
because the moon does
not have an atmosphere
to kind of smooth
over the impact.
So the consensus is that
only after the Late Heavy
Bombardment was Earth
kind of ready for life.
And we believe
that the first life
formed 3.824 billion years ago.
Remember, g for giga,
for billion years ago.
And when we talk about
life at this period,
we're not talking about
squirrels or panda bears.
We're talking about
extremely simple life forms.
We're talking about prokaryotes.
And let me give you a little
primer on that right now,
though we go into much more
detail in the biology playlist.
We're talking about prokaryotes.
And I'll compare
them to eukaryotes.
Prokaryotes are,
for the most part,
unicellular organisms
that have no nucleuses.
They also don't have
any other membrane-bound
what we call organelles or
these little parts of the cells
that perform specific
functions, like mitochondria.
So their DNA is just
kind of floating around.
So let me draw this
character's DNA.
So it's just floating
around, just like that.
And prokaryote literally
means before kernel
or before a nucleus.
Eukaryotes do have a nucleus,
where all of their DNA is.
So this is the nuclear membrane.
And then all of its DNA is
floating inside of the nucleus.
And then it also has other
membrane-bound organelles.
Mitochondria is kind of
the most famous of them.
So it also has things
like mitochondria.
We'll learn more about
that in future videos.
Mitochondria, we
believe, is essentially
one prokaryote crawling inside
of another prokaryote and kind
of starting to become
a symbiotic organism
with each other.
But I won't go into
that right now.
But when we talk about
life at this period,
we're talking about prokaryotes.
And we still have
prokaryotes on the planet.
Bacteria and archaea are
examples of prokaryotes.
And just to give you a little
bit of a tidbit right here,
this kind of shows our
current understanding
of where we think things
branched off from.
So at this point of the
tree is some common ancestor
to prokaryotes and eukaryotes.
So these are the
prokaryotes right
over here, the bacteria
and the archaea.
And here is the eukaryote.
And this first living
thing, or this first set
of living things, we
think might have just
been some type of
self-replicating molecules.
And slowly, some membrane
might have come around,
and it became a little
bit more organized.
DNA, RNA-- maybe RNA was that
original self-replicating
molecule-- became
the method of kind
of transmitting information
from one generation to the next.
So it's really still
an open question
of exactly what
that first life is
or even how do you
define that first life.
But based on studying the
genetic makeup of molecules
of current organisms, this is
how we think the tree of life
came about.
So we have one common ancestor.
Then they broke apart.
And then the archaea
and eukaryotes
have a common ancestor that's
different from the bacteria.
And we'll talk more
about that in the future.
And this right here, just
so you can visualize it,
this is an example of bacteria.
This is E. coli Or
Escherichia coli.
It's just an
example of bacteria.
It comes in a bunch
of shapes and forms.
But it's a
prokaryotic life form.
And the earliest life forms,
we also think were anaerobes.
These are things
that did not-- one,
that they did not need oxygen.
And they, for the most part,
found oxygen poisonous.
And the earliest life
forms also probably
did not perform photosynthesis.
They might have gotten their
energy from other sources,
chemically, from this kind of
extremely volatile environment
that they were in at that time.
So if we fast forward a little
bit-- and this is actually
a major event in the
history of Earth.
And these are huge time
scales we're talking about.
Remember, I'm kind of
just nonchalantly saying,
oh, 4.6 billion years
ago to 3.8 billion.
Oh, that's just
800 million years.
Remember-- and I'll
talk about this.
Grass has only existed
for 50 million years.
This is 800 million years.
Humans and chimpanzees only
diverged 5 million years ago.
This is 800 million years
we're talking about,
from ancient Greece
to now, we're
only talking about 2,500 years.
You multiply that
times 1,000, you
get 2 and 1/2 a million years.
And this is 800 million
years we're talking about.
So these are extremely
huge periods of time.
And that's why we
call them eons.
Eons are 500 million
to a billion years.
Now, the dividing line between
the Hadean Eon and the Archean
Eon-- and it's kind of
a fuzzy dividing line,
but most people place it
about 3.8 billion years ago.
It's kind of the earliest
rocks that we can observe.
And so we have rocks from, that
are roughly 3.8 billion years
ago.
So we kind of put that as the
beginning of the Archean Eon.
And so there's two things there.
One, rocks have survived from
the beginning of the Archean
Eon.
And also, that's
roughly when we think
that the first life existed.
And so we're now
in the Archean Eon.
And you might say,
oh, maybe Earth
is a more pleasant place now.
But it would not be.
It still has no to little
oxygen in the environment.
If you were to go to
Earth at that time,
it might have looked
something like this.
It would have a
been a reddish sky.
You would have had nitrogen
and methane and carbon dioxide
in the atmosphere.
There would have been
nothing for you to breathe.
There still would have been
a lot of volcanic activity.
This right here, these are
pictures of stromatolites.
And these are
formed from bacteria
that are bringing in
sediment particles.
And over time, these
things get built up.
But the most significant
event in the Archean period,
at least in my
humble opinion, was
what we believe
started to happen
about 3.5 billion years ago.
And this is prokaryotes,
or especially bacteria,
evolving to actually
utilize energy from the sun,
to actually do photosynthesis.
And the real fascinating
byproduct of that,
other than the fact that they
can now use energy directly
from the sun, is that it
started to produce oxygen,
so starts to produce oxygen.
And at first, this
oxygen, even though it
was being produced
by the cyanobacteria,
by this blue-green
bacteria, it really
didn't accumulate
in the atmosphere.
Because you had all
of this iron that
was dissolved in the oceans.
And let me be clear.
All of the life that we're going
to be talking about for really
the next several billion years,
it all occurred in the ocean.
We had no ozone layer now.
The land was being irradiated.
The land was just a completely
inhospitable environment
for life.
So all of this was
occurring in the ocean.
And so the first
oxygen that actually
got produced, it actually,
instead of just being released
into the atmosphere,
it ended up bonding
with the iron that was dissolved
in the ocean at that time.
So it actually
didn't have a chance
to accumulate in the atmosphere.
And when we fast forward
past the Archean period,
we're going to see, that once
a lot of that iron was oxidized
and the oxygen really
did start to get released
in the atmosphere,
it actually had--
it's funny to say--
a cataclysmic effect
or a catastrophic effect
on the other anaerobic life
on the planet at the time.
And it's funny to
say that because it
was a catastrophe for them.
But it was kind of a necessary
thing that had to happen for us
to happen.
So for us, it was a blessing
that this cyanobacteria
started to pump
out a lot of oxygen
and eventually oxidized
all of the iron
and eventually released a lot
of oxygen into the atmosphere
and killed off all of
this anaerobic bacteria,
so that eventually we
could-- us oxygen-breathing
organisms could come about.
But that's not going
to happen for a while.
We still have a
few billion years
before things start
flopping around on the land.
Anyway, see you
in the next video.